not only are mentors in battle shown in
anime called but they also tend to be
memorable besides the main characters
and villains these people tend to be the
best or most prominent side characters
and they serve to guide the hero on his
quest to become stronger anyway you can
say they're the real mvp unfortunately
being an anime mentor also comes with
the well-known occupational hazard but
we're not here to see mentors dying are
we we have a separate list for sad
moments and all but for today we're here
to bask in their glory to see them at
their peak at their best and what better
way to show it in a battle shonen than
to give focus to some of the best and
most memorable battles featuring them so
strap yourselves in as we take a ride
through some of my favorite mental
battles in action shonen we start things
off with benimaru vs holy soul
benimaru and cool fights it seems to go
together we already featured this
awesome mentor before so how about
another fight this time against holy
souls shadows anyone out for a one man
army fight because benimaru brings the
heat when he single-handedly takes down
the holy soul shadows in spectacular
fashion even when they try to mob him he
simply uses them as a showcase of power
blasting them multiple times over even
when the shadows look like they landed a
hit it just became a scene to build up
benimaru's spectacular finish one of the
nice fire force fights for us to
remember although calling it a fight
would be a bit of a stretch domination
is more like it
[Music]
is
up next is koro sensei versus yanagisava
jigokuno yonayo
i've talked long about goro sensei being
one of the most overpowered characters
in anime but i haven't featured an
assassination classroom fight at all
have i well that's gonna change today
and we end that with a banger of a fight
a climactic showdown between goro sensei
and yanagisava is pretty much all you
want from a final fight in a series like
assassination classroom yanagisama
played the final boss role to perfection
and gave goro sensei a run for his money
the fight's filled with revelations
intense attacks and jaw-dropping
sequences it also has its share of drama
featuring guyana and even reaper 2.0
upon his defeat truly an impressive and
awesome way to wrap up this anime that's
given his fans some of their best years
[Applause]
we take to the fate universe for the
next entry chiron vs
achilles chiron versus achilles is one
of the more underlooked fights and i
don't blame you fate apocrypha is in my
eyes the most niche anime of the fate
universe it doesn't have the legacy of
stay night or zero nor does it have such
a huge game and cinematic presence as
grand order yeah it keeps up the fake
tradition of having crisp eye-catching
fights and this kiron vs achilles fight
is the poster child for that i talked
about this fight in one of my best
hand-to-hand fight videos because it's
just that good it's a good old broad
where the anime team really went out of
their way to capture the action and the
barrage of attacks the two throw at each
other if you're looking for amazingly
animated fights in fantasy action anime
then feel free to give this one a shot
all for one versus all might is the
definition of hype
[Music]
one thing my hero academia does so well
is build hype he spent a lot of time
building all might as this unstoppable
force of good someone even the strongest
villains tremble at the site of he
easily wins all his fights and saves his
students numerous times in impressive
fashion but every light has a shadow an
apt foil that serves to provide a
balance in power and that's why everyone
was so excited to hear that all might
was finally going to fight his
counterpart all for one and the fight
delivered there's just this magical
feeling seeing the two strongest forces
in my hero academia duke it out for real
all for one versus all might is a fight
that left everyone both in universe and
out of universe in awe the united states
of smash moment here is still one of my
favorite moments even as more seasons
have come and gone another good thing to
know is that this is one status altering
fight for the whole universe glad to see
all might retiring in style and if
seeing all might's greatest moments got
you all hyped imagine how hyped i was
when the channel hit a million subs i'm
here to just take a moment to thank you
for all the help in getting the channel
to reach that landmark it really means
everything to me thank you but let's not
stop there okay heck if my newer videos
continue to give you fun times then why
don't you hit that like button subscribe
and share the channel with your shown
and loving friends we've got loads of
videos here and i'd be more than happy
to see the vinichu family grow hope you
have a good time ahead with the rest of
the list nothing's a better definition
of constant improvement than black
clover and this fighting body zip
[Music]
dante one of the best fights black clove
has given us and it's fitting that it
happens towards the end of the anime
saving the best for last yeah am i right
what i like about this fight isn't just
the actual fighting yet the fighting's
great and i'm all for seeing more of
yami's dark magic it's all shades of
awesome but what i feel is the most
important element of this fight is how
it proves arsdas development you'd be
hard-pressed to find that little
annoying kid from early to be this
badass and here he stands toe-to-toe
fighting alongside his captain against
one of the most powerful enemies they've
encountered so far aston matured and
badass at this point and you bet it's a
source of pride for yami his pupils all
grown up has become one of the most
reliable allies he can ever ask for
here's another amazing final fight with
gintoki versus futsuro
what better way for gintama the final to
end with the grandest battle of them all
kintoki finally faces utsuru in a
spectacle that gintama fans will forever
remember one underrated thing about this
fight is the foreshadowing remember when
this was teased all the way back with
everyone thinking takasugi is going to
be the final villain just an added layer
of bonus to what ends up being a really
amazing fight gintama is no stranger to
making the fans feel a rollercoaster of
emotions that this fight encapsulates
that in a big way i also love how the
fight turns out to be quite methodical
instead of showering us with fireworks
there's the whole use of silence and
flashbacks to build everything up as the
two go at it it truly adds to the moment
the solemn ambiance and it gives each
blow more gravity if you get what i'm
saying a great battle that serves as a
great finale one that amazes us while
reminding us of the journey to get here
go joe versus jogo is next on the list
this one's a favorite not specifically
because of some mind-blowing fight
choreography but simply because of how
much of a landmark moment it was it's
the first time we see gojo flex his
power over someone and mapa just had to
put up some of their best work in the
art department for this let's be real
this early in the show it's never going
to be some intense back and forth
between the mentor character showing off
his strength and a character who didn't
seem like such a big threat it's just
gojo showing how superior he is by using
this as a tutorial level to his pupil
but boy did he make a pretty show out of
it i'm not sure if i'd rank this above
hollow purple if we're talking about
spectacular gojo moments but it's the
one that gained more buzz from the
community and that's understandable
because the latter's the icing on top of
the already amazing hanami fight
here's another supernatural anime fight
on the list tengen vs gutaro
[Music]
it's kind of tough to lock this fight
down with a start point to an end point
the climactic battle in demon slayer's
entertainment district asks pretty much
a chain of fights with participants
tagging in and out of action and being
given their respective focus that's also
what makes its presentation so
interesting and unique the whole
sequence has its fair share of epic
moments but i think that the tangent
parts are my favorite the nezuko parts
are cool and all but it's when tengen
takes the forefront do i feel the most
excited every time we see a pillar in
action it's always cool but tengen takes
it a step further with his blitzing
style combining speed with power and
taking the fight to the upper moon duo
dangerous joining the fight gives the
battle a much welcome boost in height
being the first time our protagonist
joins his mentor in a fight to this
level
finally we have kakashi vs obito
kakashi versus obito for the most part
seems to be a fight that gets hype based
on the history it's a long time coming
between the two and we know it's gonna
be big when we see the longtime friends
turned enemies finally face off with one
another it's that naruto versus sasuke
of another generation and the anime made
sure to hammer that point home i mean in
some ways this one's even better than
the actual naruto versus sasuke fight
it's a battle that's all about blazing
speed combined with trademark naruto
magic system i also like how physical
combat comes into play as the two blitz
each other there are some rather funny
comments that claim that this is the
most actual ninja-like fight in the
series but hey can we disagree with that
just look at these two go it's a fight
that has a good story great gravity and
huge stakes all done in a package though
while doesn't match the special effects
extravaganza modern fights have still
gave us a good moment to remember
and that wraps up today's list mentor
fights are the coolest aren't they i
hope you enjoyed the video once again
thank you for watching i hope to see you
again in the next video which is
scheduled to come out in just a few days
time make sure to bring your friends
along for the ride too